imaginez une connexion à internet avec
de la lumière eh bien ce n'est plus un
rêve la société oled comme l'a
développée à partir de recherches
initiées au sein de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
vous pouvez vous connecter à internet
avec un modem bidirectionnelle donc dans
les deux sens ça fonctionne dans les
deux sens c'est la lumière visible qui
transmet le signal internet 2 du
lampadaire vert vers l'ordinateur à
travers un petit tube clé usb qu'on n'a
pas la gueule
grâce à cela nous avons une connectivité
sans ondes complètement sécurisé dans
les bureaux c'est à dire que le signal
le traversant pas les murs comme le wifi
saby confère des niveaux de sécurité
exceptionnelles oled comme rentre dans
une nouvelle phase l'industrialisation
à partir de cette technologie des
applications sont proposées notamment au
secteur hospitalier et du transport on
est aujourd'hui un pionnier mondial de
la technologie à une vingtaine de
brevets qui ont été déposées il est
temps à présent d'en faire des produits
commercialisables industrialisable afin
de de créer un business pérenne pour la
société après des études d'ingénieur
bastien béchadergue s'est lancé dans un
projet de recherche sur le lit fille au
sein du laboratoire d'ingénierie des
systèmes de versailles aujourd'hui c'est
son premier jour de travail chez oled
comme pour la communication pour les
problèmes de des technologies radio qui
arrive pas à satisfaire toute la demande
on arrive tout à coup avec l'éclairage
c'est ça a un côté un peu magique à
transmettre des données
j'étais vraiment enthousiasmé par cette
idée là prochain rendez vous important
le cs de las vegas du 9 au 12 janvier
pour présenter le premier produit
commercialisé de howlett comme
récompensé par deux prix internationaux